I'm happy to be here sit up here with my
a cup of coffee so that
I the it seems to me in a way that the
coming of non-woven scholars into the
morn field was started and I see Richard
is is Franny Franny Franny but way back
in nineteen seventy three there's that
in 1972 the fall of nineteen seventy-two
at the Western history association where
we met at we met I think we met it to in
New Haven and all the moment scholars
were to get together for dinner and the
waiter came around and asked if anybody
wanted to drink and and Richard said oh
no no no no and I said just stomach I've
always found a way to let people know
that I'm a Methodist though if if it had
been 30 years ago even a Methodist
couldn't have had agreements ok whenever
election time comes around the General
Authorities of the Church of Jesus
Christ of latter-day saints remind local
leaders across the United States to
encourage the members of the church in
their wards to take an active part in
the political process in a priesthood
meeting in one of the many Ward's in
Provo Utah not long ago this reminder
was delivered by one of the high priest
he said that at a specified time the
Republican men and the ward should
gather in a nearby school auditorium at
the same time the Democratic men should
gather in the school's broom close that
is a story that is I regard as a true
story since it came to me from Bert
William Wilson the the eminent
folklorist
of Mormon studies it is possible that
there may be isolated Ward's in blue
states where there are more Democrats
than Republicans but the number of
Democrats in virtually every sector of
Utah and the other states in the Mormon
culture region except the urban areas
where non-mormons live and they now call
themself Gentiles live and live an
incredible disparity now exists between
highly Republican conservative Mormons
and moderate Democrat Mormons because
this state of affairs has existed
without a change in the outcome of
presidential elections in Utah since
nineteen sixty eight in the and in the
vote for governor since 1984 and also
because a great majority of LDS church
leaders in Utah moved into the
republican party after the Mormons
people party was forced to give way in
order for you to become a state in 1896
many modern observers are under the
impression that Utah has always been
extremely conservative yet as the
history of Mormonism reveals this
movement was not conservative but
virtually revolutionary throughout the
19th century it's more members
experimented with radical social and
economic systems although it was also a
time for a theocracy or as it called
itself a Theo democracy that was both
powerfully patriarchal and strictly
hierarchical if Mormons in Utah were not
always conservative and they were not it
was often Republican in the last
centuries early decades it is important
to remember in the in the early decades
however that the Republicans were the
progressives but as these timelines and
someone is going to put the timeline up
there
on this the sweet as this time line
indicates the Mormon state did not
always vote Republican as is obvious in
this timeline that combines the boat in
Utah for both the governor of the state
above in the red above and the president
of the nation with the numbers across
the bottom by far the most democratic
Utah voters ever were in the years from
1932 to 1948 during the Eisenhower
administration it was solidly a
Republican a period when Mormon apostle
Ezra Taft Benson was Secretary of
Agriculture the highest civil executive
office ever held by a letter de st. up
to that time but following the
Eisenhower the state voted for john f
kennedy in 1960 and for Lyndon Johnson
in 1964 and Democratic Governors
suffered served Utah from 1964 through
1980a for even though the state voted
for republican candidates for president
during those years since 1984 till now
however the state has been so solidly
Republican and intensely conservative
that it has seemed unnecessary for
National Republican candidates to do
much campaigning in the state before
returning to this remarkable
conservative turn that led to the high
priest just about latter-day saints who
were Republican median in auditorium
well latter-day saints who where
Democrats could meet in a bloom broom
closet it is necessary to examine very
briefly Utah during the New Deal years
when the state's population continued to
be overwhelmingly Mormon
as early as 1902 the administration of
the church shifted away from his
traditional pattern I'm saving time by
not saying of the Church of Jesus Christ
of latter-day saints but it's always us
here you know court shifted away from
its traditional pattern of encouraging
all latter-day saints especially new
converse to settle in the Great Basin
but their advice to stay in the world
but not of it of it was often honored in
the breach accepting in a few urban
areas where the church was organized
into local stakes wards and branches
plus a few areas on the Pacific coast
the Mormon world was still subdivided
into Zion and the mission field and so
many mission field Mormons wanted to
resign in Zion despite the reality that
the resources of the Mormon culture
region could not support all of them
that it caused trouble this was
especially true in utah mormon ism
central place where agriculture had been
the main source of income throughout the
19th century in the 20th century this
same situation obtained even though the
state's economy was increasingly
integrated into the nation national
economy through the commercialization of
agriculture the advent of a sizable
business sector and most particularly
the group growth of corporate mining and
of manufacturing notably notably beet
sugar and the processing of agricultural
products the development of railways
other than the Union Pacific and the
coming of urban utilities including
interurban railways from Salt Lake City
to ogwen Ogden and to Utah County
allowed the population to take advantage
of the new economy by daily traveling to
where manufacturing was taking place as
a result you
became the most industrialized state in
the Mountain West for all that however
since so much of the state's
manufacturing was tied to agriculture
the agricultural depression that hit the
nation in the 1920s was devastating to
Utah the state was suffering
economically long before the advent of
the Great Depression a circumstance that
surely added to the vote that defeated
senator reid's Smoot in 1932 and lead
led to the state's choice of a
Democratic president and no this check
mark in 1936 skills will get that in a
minute the collapse of the the stock
market in 1929 and the onset of the
Great Depression led Utah to an
unemployment rate of thirty five point
eight percent not surprisingly as New
Deal programs were put into place to
help the poor and the unemployed Utah
citizens were quick to take advantage of
them the utah state government likewise
accepted available funds from Washington
to establish state welfare programs and
other state programs to assist the
unemployed in 1933 more than a fourth of
the Utah population was not exactly on
the dole but accepting various forms of
public health during these early pretend
I should say that much of these
disinformation about you talk on me
comes from a very good articles in a
book called Utah's history that was
edited by Richard Paul and Anton of
Zander and in a few others that was
written by John Bluth and Wayne hidden
during these early Depression years
Elias LDS leaders encouraged church
vers to avoid public assistance if at
all possible and in 1936 sure church
president Heber J grant wants a Democrat
but by this time a strong Republican
placed a letter to all latter-day saints
on the front page of the deseret news
urging him to vote against President
Franklin Roosevelt rather than following
his advice however a majority of Mormon
voters all across the state voted for
FDR in these same years the church moved
to establish its well-known church
welfare program also designed to help
church members who were impacted by this
stagnant economy as soon as it was well
underway LDS leaders encouraged church
members to turn to their local wards for
assistance rather than depending on the
government but the no strings attached
helped the government provided remain
the primary source of assistance until
the economy rebounded as that the nation
moved toward World War two in fact in
1935 and 1936 public assistance was ten
times as great as the accountable
assistance of the church welfare plane
that was a shock to me I knew that it
was a lot but I didn't know it was that
great life in Utah was better in the
1940s as the economy recovered and as
the Latter day Saints found themselves
at one with the nation in their desire
to defeat Japan and the Axis powers in
the immediate post-war years the church
was at pains to regather the Saints who
had been scattered during and
immediately after the war organizing or
reorganizing the church all throughout
the Mormon
region as well as along the Pacific
coast additionally the church many of
whose missions had been halted due to
the war under two extraordinary mission
activities and saw the church then begin
to expand both in numbers and in space
organized into steaks and wards and
branches of course many branches the
decade of the 1950s was one of
astonishing activity in Mormonism center
place church growth was occurring
outside as well as inside the United
States as such an undreamed-of rate that
the pre-war church organization was
finding it impossible to keep up with
building enough buildings and finding
enough lay clergy to lead all the new
saints I ran across the the memories of
a state president from South America who
at come first time went to his went to
the head of the building department and
said i have i've asked and asked and
haven't heard from you we need a new
building in wherever it was i can't
remember exactly what place it was and
the the head of the department just said
well put it in writing and he said i did
put it in writing i never heard from you
and the man pointed to a pile as as tall
as his chair and it says it must be in
there somewhere that's how busy the
church was and the leaders were trying
to keep up with the growth what to do
about the deteriorating urban area
around church headquarters with another
problem as was managing all the
genealogical
that was gathered from up front
throughout the world people probably do
not know but the great huge church
office building on the campus in salt
lake city has its its size and its form
because it was designed to hold file
cabinets that would hold all the
genealogical material that was being
collected from throughout the world they
did not know that this could be done on
one of those little files by the end the
computers they didn't know that the
church was being led by its priesthood
organization and its auxiliary the
female relief society the sunday school
diploma your organization the young
men's and young women's mutual aid
associations and the heads of
departments such as genealogy buildings
mission programs and so on each
auxiliary and department had a few
employees but at that time in the 1950s
the church had no real bureaucracy to
begin to k take charge of the statistics
and everything else about church growth
what it did have or what it did have was
a I'm sorry I keep putting however in
there it's not in the paper well what it
did will have was a first-rate public
affairs department which had been in
existence for well over half a century
the type that department caught up the
excitement of the age and stayed busy
issuing press releases disseminating
information about the church in edits
growth the Mormon Tabernacle Choir
called Americans America's choir by
President Eisenhower and its successful
members like swimsuit
designer rose marie Reed golfer Johnny
Miller and actor victory at the same
time recognizing that the public
perception of the latter-day saints was
growing even ever more positive its
members promoted the publication of
articles about the saints in the print
media one such article was published as
originally written and that's important
originally written in Reader's Digest
competitor carnet in April 1952 despite
warnings that it was filled with
falsehoods from the Dean of the
University of Utah's graduate school
sterling McMurray to whom the carnet
sent it for review he said it was filled
with falsehoods written by Andrew him
Hamilton it was published at written and
it was called those amazing Mormons it
provided a picture of a people with all
the Boy Scout virtues who didn't drink
alcohol or caffeine didn't smoke kept a
year's larder full of food steps and of
greatest importance took care of their
own it was a portrait of a attractive
productive people who had managed to get
through the Great Depression without
depending on government handouts that
the LDS Church adopted and as it
publicized its church welfare plan and
its food storage policy moreover as
lifelong members of the church lifelong
Mormons became models for all the new
LDS converts church members to adopted
this picture of themselves as well in an
environment filled with concerns about
atom bombs stories about personal air
raid shelters and the dangers of
communism
this the embrace of such a picture
called for forgetting the reality of the
Great Depression years and the veracity
of stories about Lauren isms
experimentation with a radical social
system that could have changed the
nature of the Mormon family and a tiara
Theo democracy that would have made the
woman stand apart from other Americans
and have kept it a small group a small
ethnic group the Mormons who probably
celebrated the picture of those amazing
Mormons more than any other was most
likely apostle Ezra Taft Benson whose
tenure as agriculture secretary had in
Washington had convinced him that
communism was the greatest of all
dangers to the United States and to his
church in a very real sense over
partisan politics took a backseat in the
30 years after World War two the state
voted for Harry Truman for president in
1948 but for a Republican governor in
1950 and in the next three decades the
vote the state continued to vote for
Democrats for president and Republicans
for years for governor for years or vice
versa vote for Republicans for President
and Democrats for the government but at
the ground level a conservative movement
started spreading across across Utah
much like the newly-introduced kudzu
plant was spreading a call across the
south the leaders I live there I know
about person
the leaders in this radical conservatism
were apostle Benson his son Reed who was
by that time the vice president of the
the the the the john birch society ARS
wilkinson president of BYU and w cleon
skousen a member of the BYU faculty he
had worked for the FBI and later was
chief of police in Salt Lake City and
who was writing hooks at that time about
the dangers of communism and the way it
had been a danger all through history
interestingly enough cleon skousen books
have had a revival of popularity since
they were taken up by one new
conservative mormon but it was at this
time that the books had enormous
popularity though I noticed that in one
of the reports about what government
what Republican candidates were reading
the governor of Texas was reading a
Cleon Skousen took as one of his one of
the things he was reading these days
Benson who had always been conservative
but during his years in Washington as a
member of Eisenhower's cabinet he became
so arrogantly any communists that this
view came to dominate his thinking
during his presence in the nation's
capital use me
fellow members of the Council of the
twelve had been so greatly appreciated
preciate evahh station in the national
government that expressions of pride in
the task he was a complexing were the
general rule in comments about him even
among those apostles who would oppose
this political position in the years
after he returned to Salt Lake City but
during his first post cabinet interview
with Church President David o mckay he
was accompanied by his son Reed who was
already active in the John Birch Society
Benson returned to Utah clearly hoping
that his church would move directly into
the bird society's fold he clearly hoped
that his advocacy for this extremely
anti-communist political organization
could convince president McKay to
support him although McKay never placed
the church over which he presided in
league with the anti-communist cause he
did give Benson permission to make an
anti-communist address to the LDS annual
conference Benson had allowed the
magazine published by the society to use
his photograph on the public cover and
he almost managed to get President McKay
to allow his photograph to be used on
the cover of the john birch society
magazine as well but even after it was
set in print this was headed off by
apostle Hubie Brown a Democrat but the
radical conservatism of apostle Benson
surely promoted the spread of support
for the cause he supported among
latter-day saints in local awards
throughout the state routes throughout
the state and the region in the fall of
nineteen sixty I moved with my family to
Logan Utah returning to school that year
and changing my major from music to
history in the course of my studies
had to take a senior seminar in which
students were required to write term
papers using primary sources at least
two of the topics selected by the
seniors in the class had to do with Utah
during the Depression it was there that
I learned the fact that Mormons in Utah
had been as likely as any other poor or
unemployed citizen of the United States
to take advantage of the new teal
assistance programs that was one of
Utah's deep dark secrets it did not go
along with those amazing moments and
took care of themselves the other
interestingly enough at that time was
the existence of polygamy in Mormon
history it was played down so much that
one would have not hardly known that it
was there the attitude was that only two
or three percent of the Mormons
practiced it anyway and the picture of
the picture of Mormonism presented to
our family when we were visited almost
weekly by ward missionaries was the
picture of those amazing Mormons perhaps
they thought we were potential converts
they don't know how strong it is to be
lifelong Methodist
this effort to forget the past was very
much a part of the move toward political
conservatism that we saw around us and
apart of this move I do not talk about
it because max Mueller is going to talk
about the problem of the blacks at least
in 19 in 2012 at that time was that many
many of the conservatives thought that
the asking of the church to make blacks
equal to whites in obtaining the Mormon
priesthood was a communist plot as Ezra
tennis Taft Benson and the John Birch
Society said this effort to forget the
past was so important at that time
consulate consequently I was not
surprised when I was told by the
director of the LDS Church historical
department that when the Deseret press
published the building the City of God
community and cooperation among the
Mormons Arrington Fox and may a member
of the Council of the twelve was so
distressed that he asked that the book
be threaded so much for remembering and
celebrating Mormonism history and its
story of the extraordinary efforts the
Saints made to live as had their early
Christians to elder Benson for he was
the apostle asking for the shredding of
the book Christian communitarianism was
simply too much like 20th century
communism that threatened the world when
Benson became president of the church
liberal Mormons were relieved that
instead instead of chipped taking the
furture CH further into political
conservatism
he turned his attention to moving the
Book of Mormon from icon to text by
asking every church member to make
reading the Mormon scripture a
devotional duty into the building of LDS
temples and celebrating the ordinances
there in this movement from icon to text
was also happening in the evangelical
movement as at that time the king james
version of the bible was soll to
Protestants throughout the country to
Jews on their coffee tables but as
Martin Marty once said its SAT there but
was never opened and in Mormon
households the Book of Mormon was the
same it often SAT there but only in the
modern era has it been read as a
devotional duty and its its content
discovered as inspirational it was that
his work in that it was not that his
work in politics was not important no
doubt he was certain that it was
possible to be a good Democrat and a
good bird and a good Mormon it was
simply that his work in the area of
politics was done Utah and then the
remainder of the Mormon culture region
is if not more is as if not more
conservative than any other part of
nation thanks to knowing about
considering forgetting the past and
providing the world with a picture of
Mormons
as amazing